est ce qu'on voit dans les quinze jours
qui viennent de s'écouler et puis la
deuxième c'est que si on continue on a
de bonnes chances de pouvoir retrouver
progressivement plus de normalité mais
qu'il faut continuer encore un petit peu
d'où le rendez vous donné le 1er
décembre
oui avec une déclaration de la sorte et
puis une amélioration des chiffres
notamment réanimation ben est il
aujourd'hui possible de demander au delà
du mois de descendre du premier laisse
un bon français de continuer à
restreindre comme ça beaucoup nous
partie de leur vie notre objectif c'est
vraiment de pouvoir ré ouvrir le plus de
commerce et d'activité économique à
partir du 1er décembre je pense aussi
aux agences immobilières dont moi j'ai
la charge va en parler qui pour l'heure
ne faut pas faire de visite
après je crois qu'il va falloir inventer
aussi une manière de vivre de façon
intermédiaire avec quelques restrictions
qui probablement resteront pour que nous
ne soyons pas toujours en train de voir
le virus augmente et reprendre le
contrôle se redonnaient un peu d'oxygène
et donc cesser cette partie là qu'il
faut inventer à partir de dessins mais
il est beaucoup question de
l'acceptabilité de ces mesures par les
français on imagine que ça préoccupe
aussi au gouvernement est ce qu'avec des
déclarations comme celle là disons que
malgré tout la situation s'améliore que
le pic de l'épidémie c'était vendredi
dernier à ce que ça va être compliqué de
faire accepter aux français que les
commerces ne rouvre pas le 1er décembre
si tel est le cas et je crois que c'est
aussi important de montrer que nos
efforts payent ce sont de gros efforts
c'est très difficile ça met beaucoup
d'activités économiques en difficulté ça
restera aussi nos libertés individuelles
de se déplacer de rencontrer des amis la
question des cultes qui a été posée
fortement ce week-end c'est important de
montrer qu'on ne fait pas tout ça pour
rien et que c'est encourageant que
l'épidémie progresse moins vite que dans
la période précédente et 7 ça montre
aussi l'utilité de ces mesures donc moi
je pense que les gens sont responsables
et comprenne je trouve qu'au contraire
les français respectent globalement bien
sûr c'est parfois difficile mais je en a
besoin de transparence aussi je crois
que c'est important de parler aux gens
comme à des adultes
et puisque vous parlez des cultes on a
vu à la mobilisation des catholiques
notamment ce week-end pour demander à ce
que les messes puisse se tenir est ce
que
vous êtes pour accorder aux catholiques
le droit d'aller à la messe moi je
trouve très bien que hi la réunion ait
lieu aujourd'hui entre les représentants
des cultes et le gouvernement ça sera
discutée aujourd'hui ça fait partie de
tous les sujets de restriction qu'il
faut contre est globalement pas
spécifiquement pour les cultes plutôt
que sur d'autres sujets donc j'attends
de voir aussi ce qui sortira de la
concertation mais je pense qu'il faut
qu'on soit contiennent encore je pense
que le principal message c'est tenir
encore un peu dans les restrictions dans
lesquelles nous ici si les catholiques à
faire la démonstration que dans une
église on peut tenir la distanciation
social sièges sur deux ou sur trois
pourquoi pas les cinémas et les théâtres
c'est pour ça que je dis que à mon avis
l'important c'est de tenir dans le
système dans lequel nous sommes encore
quelques jours donc il ya un désastre à
j-1 avant le premier dessin les réunions
est la réunion avec les cultes a lieu
cet après-midi au gouvernement écoute et
donc on a fait beaucoup d'ajustements
successifs mais l'esprit dans lequel
nous sommes
c'est de tenir ces restrictions encore
quelque temps pour soulager notre
système hospitalier est aussi simplement
parce que la maladie progresse et moi je
pense aux personnes qui sont malades
avec une forme grave de la maladie et à
leurs proches voilà nous leur devons ça
et sur noël évidemment noël s'inquiète
relais français est ce que le
gouvernement pourra dire oui vous
pourrez aller passer noël en famille est
ce que c'est à ça que travail le
gouvernement ça on l'a bien compris mais
est-ce que dès le 1er décembre vous
pourrez dire ça ou français bien sûr
qu'on espère pouvoir donner un message
positif sur les fêtes mais là encore
c'est trop tôt un mot sur le vaccin jean
castex dans une interview au monde ce
week-end a dit craindre que les français
ne se fassent pas assez vacciner est ce
que vous partagez sa crainte et son
inquiétude est ce qui est sûr c'est
qu'on a vu monter des inquiétudes face
au vaccin aux vaccins au pluriel tous
types de vaccins confondus dans les dix
quinze 15 dernières années
le vaccin en fait c'est un bénéfice
individuel mais c'est surtout un
bénéfice collectif
donc il faut que chacun accepte un geste
pour soi même et pour les autres là
compte tenu de ce qu'elle co vide de la
la menace que ça fait peser sur nos vies
quotidiennes
je me dis que la vaccination sera
probablement plus attendue est donc plus
accepter mais ça revient à cette
question du civisme de notre capacité à
faire quelque chose pour nous et pour
les autres heures sur les vaccins il ya
déjà quatre vaccins obligatoires en
france faudra pilot rendre obligatoire
pas pour l'instant on n'en est pas là
pour l'instant on attend les premiers
vaccins les premières autorisations de
mise sur le marché la première diffusion
la première question c'est d'abord une
vaccination facultative et on verra
comment les français s'y engouffre on
peut garantir qu'il y en aura pour tout
le monde pour tous que le désir du moins
c'est difficile de répondre à la
question quand et comment d'abord il ya
plusieurs vaccins en compétition vous le
savez il ya plusieurs entreprises
pharmaceutiques qui développe des
vaccins qui sont différents gêner
certains ont besoin d'une scène du froid
extrêmement dur puisqu'ils sont à moins
80 degrés d'autres sont des bacs simple
classique donc
ce qui est sûr c'est que tous les
gouvernements en france et en europe ce
qui est une belle initiative européenne
sur le sujet se mobilisent pour que
quand les vaccins arrivent ils soient
disponibles mais après la question c'est
aussi celle que vous posiez de
l'acceptabilité moi je crois qu'il ya
une attente en fait du vaccin et on le
voit d'ailleurs sur le vaccin anti
grippe ou cette année-là revenir liste
jean castex
c'est encore une fois c'est difficile de
répondre à une question donc il sait pas
encore complètement posée mais il me
semble logique
une attente sur l'obligation par exemple
gérard larcher le président du sénat
était très clair il a dit moi je suis
favorable à la vaccination obligatoire
si nécessaire est ce que vous vous êtes
aussi sur cette position
moi je crois que la question se pose pas
comme ça maintenant que la question qui
se pose c'est l'arrivée du vaccin la
disponibilité du vaccin le début des
campagnes vaccinales et que c'est
seulement dans quelques mois aussi quand
on verra de quel vaccin on parle quelle
efficacité que ce sera plus facile de
répondre à la généralisation à un mot
sur un autre sujet d'actualité c'est la
politique migratoire et nicolas sarkozy
qui vendredi soir sur bfm tv a dit qu'il
faut au moins pour un temps stopper les
flux d'immigration réfléchir à la
question d'un moratoire de brève durée
et mettre ce temps à profit pour
discuter de la politique migratoire et
envoyer le message aux français qu'on a
compris leur inquiétude c'est ce qu'a
dit l'ancien président est ce que ce
serait une bonne solution pour vous ce
moratoire
moi je crois que c'est je je je ne crois
pas que ça fonctionne d'abord parce que
l'immigration c'est soit de
l'immigration économique on a toujours
besoin d'immigration économique soit des
étudiants qui viennent faire leurs
études en france et la france est un
grand pays en matière d'études soient
souvent du regroupement familial et que
dans ces trois cas cette immigration
elle est légitime et du coup je trouve
que dire
il suffit d'arrêter l'immigration pour
que tout se passe mieux me paraît pas
être une bonne réponse à ce que nous
vivons après nous avons évidemment la
question de savoir comment est ce que
les personnes qui arrivent en france et
qui arrivent notamment dans ces cas en
immigration économique immigration
étudiante regroupement familial peuvent
bien s'insérer peuvent bien être prise
en charge et c'est vrai que cette
édition-là l'immigration économique
puisque le gouvernement avait lui-même
posé la question quand edouard philippe
était premier ministre de quotas pour
l'immigration économique est ce que
c'est quelque chose dont il faut
rediscuter qu'il faut remettre sur la
table
ce qui est sûr c'est que on était
jusqu'à la crise du coc vide dans une
période économique positive avec un taux
de croissance qui augmentait avec un
chauffe un chômage pardon qui diminuait
et du coup aussi des besoins de main
d'oeuvre étrangère assez élevé parce
qu'on n'était vous vous souvenez et ça
se voyait beaucoup d'ailleurs beaucoup
d'interviews régionales on n'arrive pas
à recruter un certain nombre de métiers
en tension était présente
dans les écoles on n'arrive pas à
recruter les ehpad les domiciles des
photos qu'il ravale toujours des
secteurs dans lesquels c'est difficile
de recruter et où le fait d'avoir de la
main d'oeuvre qui n'est pas française
peut répondre à une partie des besoins
de recrutement
là on va arriver à un moment de taux de
chômage plus important parce que crise
économique parce que baisse du pib
donc la question de notre capacité à
intégrer en termes d'immigration
économique se pose de façon différente
maintenant qu'il ya quelques temps donc
peut-être que ça se regarde plus mais de
toute façon dont elle avait posé la
question de ces cas de fermeture des
frontières ne peut être qu'une question
européenne c'est la question de
l'évolution de schengen et du coup je ne
crois pas qu'il suffise de dire
désormais on reprend la main sur
l'immigration je pense la question se
pose pas mais il faut reposer la
question des quotas compte tenu des
sommes en tout cas sur l'immigration
économique je pense qu'on peut se
reposer la question sur les retraites le
sénat a décidé ce week-end à voter un
amendement pour prolonger l'âge légal de
départ à 63 ans
est ce bien le moment je crois que c'est
de la pure provocation franchement c'est
la pure provocation ce week-end au
milieu d'un plfss le financement de la
sécurité sociale la question des
retraites elle se règle par an deux
amendements
elle nécessite la question générale de
l' équilibre attrait à long terme de nos
régimes de retraite c'est la question
que nous posions avec l'universalité et
du coup dire on ride le sujet des
retraites j'ouvrirai quarante trois ans
je le juge que l'on prochain non mais en
aucun cas lourds rire globalement avec à
la fois la question de l'universalité
parce que tous nos régimes de retraite
morcelé qu'ils font quand vous faites
une carrière un peu public un peu privé
un peu salariés un peu indépendant
faites-vous cauberg et dans les
interstices des régimes de retraite et
la question de la durée elle se pose
aussi sur la durée du cycle de vie donc
c'est dire entre deux amendements entre
la poire et le fromage on règle le sujet
des retraites ça me paraît pas très
reste pour vous c'est de la provocation
est ce que c'est pas le moyen de mettre
le gouvernement face à ses
responsabilités quand on voit le déficit
des régimes de retraites le cor le
chiffre à 25 milliards est ce qu'à un
moment il va pas falloir s'attaquer à ce
problème et quand gérard larcher dit ben
c'est finalement c'est un amendement
vérité évidemment que pour
la question de l' équilibre il va
falloir poser la question de l'âge de
départ à la retraite à ce qu'il n'a pas
raison
pour l'instant notre sujet c'est la
crise la réponse à la crise
on a des projets de loi de finances et
des projets de loi de finances de la
sécurité sociale qui sont totalement
différent de d'habitude avec des
déficits plus élevés avec des dépenses
plus élevées avec moins de recettes
on est face à l'urgence on n'est pas au
moment où on mélange les avant de
traiter ce problème ce n'est pas
l'aggraver
on a aussi besoin d'un consensus on a
aussi besoin d'une négociation avec les
partenaires sociaux les partenaires
sociaux sont mobilisés sur l'assurance
chômage les partenaires sociaux sont
mobilisés sur le télétravail
ils ne sont pas mobilisés en urgence sur
les retraites maintenant on est à
contretemps et la question se posera
d'ici la fin du quinquennat
la question se reposera peut-être oui
mais là on est à contrôler une réforme
financière pas seulement la réforme
prévue à la base ce que nous proposons
c'est de lier la réforme financière et
la réforme de structure
l'autre sujet c'est cet appel appel des
110 maire de plusieurs villes qui
adresse une lettre à emmanuel macron
disons que les villes et les quartiers
prioritaires restent un angle mort du
plan de relance il demande que 1% de ce
plan de relance soient attribués aux
territoires en décrochage ce sont leurs
mots est-ce que le gouvernement va
répondre à cette demande
d'abord le gouvernement valère recevoir
ce qui est tout à fait légitime ça a été
une demande du président de la
république vous avez une date non pas
encore de date qui est fixé mais dans
les jours qui viennent ensuite les
quartiers doivent être un endroit dans
lequel on n'investit particulièrement
c'est vrai dans le domaine qui est le
mien dans le logement les discussions
sont en cours notamment avec l'anru pour
voir comment continuer national de
rénovation l'âge large part dans l'
agence nationale de rénovation urbaine
qui a eu son deuxième très grand
programme de rénovation 10 milliards
d'euros sur dix ans les discussions sont
en cours pour voir si les besoins
complémentaires existe comment est-ce
qu'on pourrait investir encore plus on a
besoin de revoir à la fois les lieux de
vie la manière dont on habite la
modernisation des quartiers aient aussi
le tissu associatif les maires ont
raison
il y a un besoin de soutenir le tissu
associatif dans les quartiers est
d'ailleurs pas que dans les quartiers et
un ma collègue olivia grégoire travail
sur le soutien aux petites associations
partout en france ces associations sont
vitales dans les quartiers de la
politique de la ville mais
sont aussi vital dans les bourgs de
taille moyenne dans les périphéries dans
un peu partout sur le territoire
français et cet appel à la solidarité
qui concerne aussi les personnes les
plus en difficulté il faut l'entendre
dans cette période on en a vraiment
besoin dans votre domaine du logement du
logement de quelle manière vous allez
l'entendre cet appel qu'est ce qui va
changer
est ce qu'il ya des choses qui vont
changer alors on est beaucoup pour un
soutien bien sûr pour les personnes à la
rue les sans domiciles fixes qu'on
héberge au maximum on est aussi en
soutien sur l'aide alimentaire
avec mon collègue olivier ferrand les
budgets sur l'aide alimentaire ont
beaucoup augmenté le soutien aux
associations a beaucoup augmenté
et puis aujourd'hui nous lançons un
observatoire sur les impayés de loyer
parce que on sait que certains français
risque d'avoir des difficultés à faire
face à leurs charges et à commencer par
leur loyer ça a extrait un fait ça
pendant la crise sanitaire les
ajustements en fait on a beaucoup
d'associations ou d'acteurs qui nous
disent on sent quelque chose mais nous
n'avons pas de données consolidées donc
moi je réunis les bailleurs sociaux
aujourd'hui action logement
les grandes associations qui sont occupe
le réseau d adil les agence
départementale d'information sur le
logement qui ont mis en place un numéro
vert pour essayer d'avoir des données
plus clair que se passe-t-il vraiment
sur les impayés de loyer évidemment
avoir des données
ça permettra d'agir c'est l'objectif
avec un rapport en imagine qui va être
rendu avec des chiffres le plus vite
possible là l'idée c'est de mettre
ensemble les chiffres de tous ceux qui
observent sous une forme ou sous une
autre
et donc de pouvoir savoir si ce qu'on
entend 10 à 15% d'augmentation est ce
que c'est vraiment ce qu'on constate
c'est qu'un patient de l'augmentation de
loyer est ce que c'est vraiment le bon
chiffre
et puis surtout est ce que toutes les
aides qui existent et il ya beaucoup d'
aide via des aides locales il ya des
aides d'action logement et à des êtres
des caisses de vieillesse c'est ce que
toutes ces aides suffisent ou est-ce
qu'il faut créer une aide complémentaire
et si vraiment j'y suis prête
on va parler justement de rapport de la
fondation abbé pierre louis la fondation
abbé pierre dont trois cent mille
personnes seraient sans domicile fixe en
france le gouvernement est engagé sur 0
sans-domicile-fixe
on est loin du compte comment y arriver
alors d'abord trois cent mille personnes
ont des problèmes de logement sont très
mal logées hébergés chez des tiers en
grande difficulté mais pas à la rue
le nombre de personnes qu'on évalue
vraiment à la rue c'est-à-dire dormant
dehors c'est entre 5000 10000 15000
c'est l'ordre de grandeur
les trois cent mille personnes sont des
personnes qui sont en difficulté qui
sont hébergés dans des structures
d'urgence ou hébergés chez des tiers
en général dans de mauvaises conditions
donc ces trois cent mille personnes
nécessitent qu'on s'en occupe mais nous
hébergeons chaque jour 180 mille
personnes dans des structures
d'hébergement d'urgence que ce soit des
centres où que ce soit à l'hôtel et donc
c'est d'abord la marque d'une très
grande solidarité de l'état et des
associations vis-à-vis de ces personnes
en difficulté après il est vrai que nous
avons des demandes non satisfaites quand
vous appelez le 115 le samu social à
paris où toutes les associations qui
s'en occupe en province vous avez
beaucoup d'appels auxquels on dit désolé
pas possible de vous trouver une place
ce soir parce que les structures sont
déjà saturées ce que nous faisons depuis
mi-octobre serré augmenter massivement
les capacités d'accueil
nous avons anticipé le plan hiver moi
j'ai demandé aux préfets de monter le
nombre de places disponibles nous
travaillons avec les hôtels à réouvrir
des hôtels pour pouvoir prendre en
charge les personnes nourries ouvrons de
nouveaux centres d'hébergement d'urgence
je vais faire un point en fin de semaine
mais là on a déjà ouvert près de 5000
places supplémentaires c'est
considérable donc l'effort continu
l'objectif est de d'atteindre le
résultat que nous avions eus pendant le
premier confinement à savoir presque
plus de demandes non satisfaites nous
n'y sommes pas encore mais j'ai bon
espoir que dans les semaines qui
viennent le taux de demandes non
satisfaites bc book ça veut dire que le
nombre a augmenté par rapport au premier
confinement oui ça veut dire qu'on a mis
à l'abri beaucoup de personnes pendant
le premier confinement que ces personnes
sont toujours à l'abri encore une fois
dans des hôtels dans des centres
d'hébergement d'urgence
heureusement certains ont eu accès à des
vrais logements puisque notre objectif
final c'est bien
accès ou logement logement social
pension de famille mais que nous avons
toujours des nouvelles personnes
parce que crise économique parce que
difficultés de la vie deux nouvelles
personnes qui viennent nous voir pour
demander des places d'hébergement dont
nous on continue on l'effort est ce que
la réquisition de logements vides c'est
un sujet qui est sur la table ou est ce
que vous y opposer moi je m'oppose à
rien je m'oppose à rien je pense que
toutes les solutions sont bonnes et par
ailleurs je ne crois pas qu'il y ait une
solution magique
la réquisition de logements vides la
transformation de bureaux en logements
le développement de logement social le
développement de logements
intermédiaires les structures dites
intercalaires dans lesquelles vous savez
vous avez une friche industrielle
et puis pendant quelques temps vous
utilisez cette friche avant que ça
devienne un nouveau projet immobilier
tout ça c'est très bien c'est la somme
de toutes ces solutions qui permet
d'agir
hélas les préfets sont en train de
chercher des sites partout en france
dans lesquels on peut installer des
centres d'hébergement pour quelques
semaines pour quelques mois
nous avons aussi pérenniser déplacent
parce que vous savez notre drame c'est
souvent que on ouvre des places quelques
semaines quelques mois et puis on les
referme donc l'âge et pérenniser 14000
places c'est absolument considérable et
ça sera des places en dur c'est à des
centres qui vont rester ouverts gérés
par des associations
tout bâtiment utilisable est le bienvenu
oui là aussi on avait annoncé 500 mille
logements par an nouveau de construit or
on est très très loin du compte
la construction patine alors c'est vrai
qu'il n'a pas besoin de partout de
nouveaux logements mais là où il y en a
besoin on n'arrive pas à construire
comment faire pour sortir de l'impasse
d'abord mobiliser les maires 500 mille
logements ça a été un objectif on était
à 450 milles avant la crise qu vide
là on sera probablement en dessous de
400 milles sur les douze derniers mois
et il la crise est passée par là deux
mois de confinement poulet les
municipales donc premièrement mobiliser
les maires la construction ça passe par
un permis de conduire de construire le
permis de construire il est octroyé par
le maire si le maire diot j'ai pas que
ça à faire c'est pas mon sujet ce
vraiment nécessaire de construire pas de
permis ils sont classés mobiliser les
maires font pas toujours pas toujours
assez mobilisés donc moi j'ai signé la
semaine dernière
le pape a forcément nous mais justement
je pense que c'est une discussion
politique qu'il faut avoir entre l'état
le gouvernement les maires des
administrés les indiens pacte les
françaises sont les mêmes qui ne sont
pas d'accord pour la construction d'un
immeuble à proximité de chez eux et qui
après viennent voir le maire en disant
mon fils ma fille n'arrive pas à se
loger à proximité fait quelque chose
monsieur le maire voilà donc c'est
vraiment un sujet qui est un sujet qu'il
faut qu'on partage j'ai signé un pacte
avec la mf france urbaine et la dcf la
semaine dernière pour la mobilisation
pour la relance pour le neuf et puis
surtout ce week end à l'assemblée
nationale sur le plf
nous avons maintenu prorogé prorogé par
dont le prêt à taux zéro et les aides
fiscales type pinel pour donner que vous
de l'été devait s'adapter en 2021
finalement vous le prolonger jusqu'en
2022 pourquoi sur le lancer à taux zéro
est prorogé jusqu'à fin 2022 le pin elle
aussi et on a donné de la visibilité
après 2022 avec une best du taux normal
le maintien d'un dispositif amélioré
pour les opérations les plus exemplaires
et un engagement à soutenir le logement
intermédiaire donc de notre côté nous
donnons la visibilité économique
nécessaires au secteur de l'autre il
faut se dire que la construction ça
reste une grande cause nationale
un mot sur le marché de l'immobilier en
faisant parler au début de cette
interview actuellement par exemple les
visites de biens sont interdites en
physique cd visite virtuelle est ce que
ça ça va changer est ce que vous allez
autoriser les visites de biens
l'objectif c'est que comme pour les
petits commerces à partir du 1er
décembre on puisse redonner de la
souplesse et de la capacité à visiter
les agences immobilières sont fermées au
public les visites sont interdites
ça fait partie de toutes ces
restrictions je sais que c'est très
difficile pour le secteur j'ai des
contacts réguliers avec eux on a pu
laisser un certain nombre de choses
possibles les visites virtuelles la
signature de mandats la signature des
actes dès que possible on rouvre ça fait
partie des activités économiques on
souhaite rouvrir très vite et dernière
question parce quils un petit mot sur le
vote par correspondance
un bon il ya ceux qui défendent le vote
façon traditionnelle bulletin dans
l'urne à voter et puis ceux qui veulent
modernes
des soi-disant modernisé avec le vote
par cros est cependant si vous avez une
position sur le sujet moi je suis
inquiète des taux d'abstention qui
montrent de plus en plus on voit sur
toutes nos grandes élections et donc
toute solution qui permet d'augmenter le
taux de participation paraît
intéressante donc s'avérer intéressante
y compris celle là et merci beaucoup
c'est merci manuel vergon des traditions
voir ce matin pascal on va regarder la
une du dauphiné avec céline interview du
ministre de la santé
olivier verrons nous reprenons le
contrôle sur l'épidémie grande interview
à lire dans les journaux du groupe ebra
oui olivier ferrand qui à la fois
porteur d'espoir et puis quand même qui
met en garde en disant si on continue
pas attention ça va être compliqué à
noël donc un double message
mais c'est vrai qu'après la découverte
des vaccins la semaine dernière fait la
découverte
les premiers tests de l'acsel plus cet
entretien on commence à entrevoir un peu
de lueur au bout du tunnel
et voilà merci beaucoup merci beaucoup
nous il advenu on passe aussitôt club
des territoires
[Musique]